another night of democrats doing
everything in their power
to avoid telling you what the real plans
are
if the country actually picks joe biden
they trotted out a bunch of old familiar
faces in a desperate attempt to reassure
midwest voters
that biden will govern as a moderate
however after watching tonight's
speakers line up
every american should be alarmed it was
a veritable who's who
of failures each of whom have done
immense damage to our country
now let's start with this blast from the
past
when i ran for president in 1976 joe
biden was my first and most effective
supporter in the center he understands
that i understand dignity
our essentials rights they determine not
only our vision
but our actions more than ever that's
what we need
well god bless them but are democrats
really trying to hearken back to the
days of double-digit unemployment
inflation and of course jimmy carter's
malaise
now what's that say about their platform
today now
carter's biggest accomplishment was
getting ronald reagan elected president
tonight's lineup was kind of a time warp
amalgam it's what it would have looked
like if both parties
held a joint convention in let's say
2004.
first up john kerry is still
reporting for duty for the eight years
of the obama biden administration
we led by example we eliminated the
threat of an iran with a nuclear weapon
america deserves a president who has
looked up to
not laughed at well john kerry is best
known for windsurfing
sending pallets of cash to iranians and
secretly advising that murderous regime
behind the backs
of the president and the state
department
but sure he really cares about americans
oh wait wait there's one more another
night another former
republican i support joe biden because
beginning on day one
he will restore americans leadership and
our moral authority he'll be a president
who knows that america is strongest when
as he has said we lead both by the power
of our example
and the example of our power first his
endorsing biden
is the most unshocking thing to have
happened
in the last year okay he backed obama
twice
and hillary in 2016. and he's a nice man
and a patron he served his country
obviously but colin powell talking about
the example of
our power really while america has
turned away from the interventionist
neocons of yesteryear
the dems trot out one of the masterminds
behind iraq
you remember the one that wasted
trillions of dollars and sent thousands
of americans or their deaths
in a quixotic search for wmds
is this how joe's foreign policy would
be shaped
now the race to the bottom didn't end
there former acting attorney general
sally yates
she also made an appearance ten days in
i was fired for refusing to defend
president trump's
shameful and unlawful muslim travel ban
that was the start of his relentless
attacks on our democratic institutions
and
countless dedicated public servants
attacks on our democratic institutions
this is the woman
who president trump fired for putting
open borders
above the american people and she helped
weaponize the doj
against the trump campaign but last but
not least
was bill clinton who uttered the one
of the least aware lines of the night
and that's saying something
at a time like this the oval office
should be a command center
instead it's a storm center there's only
chaos
i don't think you should ever talk about
the oval office the man who turned the
oval office into a mini playboy mansion
probably shouldn't be lecturing
americans about what it should symbolize
he forever disgraced the office of the
presidency
with his sleazy political arrangements
that continued
after he left the white house now just
today a new pick
was revealed showing bill clinton
getting a massage
from one of jeffrey epstein's accusers
hmm so i ask are these really the
luminaries that democrats think best
represent
their party the folks you americans
want that close to power again now if so
then the choice in november should be an
easy one
but we want to go back to the days of
economic calamity
malaise and endless wars or do we want
to continue the unprecedented prosperity
strong borders and american renewal of
the trump era